meantime a lot of frustration with the
state's unemployment department
continuing tonight here at six
a group of claimants say they received
overpayment notifications
and they think that's wrong joe moeller
spoke to some of them and he's live
tonight with more on exactly what
happened
joe yeah a lot of people are getting
desperate for answers who receive these
overpayment notifications from dieter
this week now the ones we spoke with
hope this is some sort of glitch
you can't get through to anybody
unable to get through to deter claimants
are looking for answers
i'm asking to be paid back money that i
never received yeah a group of claimants
say they received an overpayment
notification from dieter this week
some claim they never received that
money in the first place like justin
rodriguez
he is being asked to pay back 16 grand i
woke up to two emails one
stating that i was overpaid by pua and
the other one that i was overpaid by
fpuc which
i never received the more people in the
same boat surfaced after a post on a
popular unemployment help facebook page
i'm at the brink of my
sanity jason letona says he is being
told to pay back more than 10 thousand
dollars
he says he was told he was qualified
then later got a disqualification letter
he showed us this overpayment letter he
got saying he owes zero dollars
he then got two more this week saying he
owes obviously i'm not going to pay
ten thousand plus dollars i don't have
ten thousand dollars
the reason i took the money i believe
everyone else who received
the unemployment money is because we're
at a point where we need the money it's
either
you know be homeless or rely on the
government
many say the appeals option is not
working on the website but
most will still try part of me says okay
let's get this appeal and let's make
sure that they just know that they're
asking me for money back that i
that they never paid me on the other
hand it's like who the heck is even
paying attention to any of us anymore
now we did reach out to dita regarding
this overpayment situation they said
they're working to answer our questions
as soon as we do
get those questions answered we'll be
sure to update the story reporting live
joe mohler eight news now